he is a freshman catcher at corners
ville high school on the corners Ville
Bulldogs 15 year old who I came first to
my attention like a lot of folks
including Deion Sanders yesterday when a
video was sent out on Twitter of
somebody who was taking video of his son
or his best friend's kid at the plate
and just noticed the catcher was
flipping the glove off of his left hand
and catching the ball that was popped up
out of the air purposely out of the
catcher's mitt into the bear left hand
and throwing it back because the young
man does not have a right arm and it was
something that caught so many people and
and I'd wanted to have this young man on
the shoulder just have to chitchat with
him his name is Luke Terry and I'm
thrilled to have him on the rich eyes
and show how are you Luke I'm pretty
good about you I'm doing great where
have I caught you you I'm gonna go right
now okay we're in school right now are
you third block Spanish right now okay
so we got you out of Spanish right now
to have this conversation yeah okay
so as they would say but de nada you're
welcome yeah so so Luke what are your
thoughts on folks that that that want to
get to meet you and get to know you
based on this video when did you know
that this video had first gotten out
there on Twitter yesterday Luke well
whenever I got to school everybody was
asking did I see the video yet and I was
like I ain't seen it and then
everybody's let me get Twitter except I
was on the text me everything and then I
finally got it and my phone's start
blowing up and what do you think of the
attention all right I like it mmm so how
would you want to be known Luke Terry I
don't know mmm when it all comes down to
it though I mean how hard have you been
working on on being a catcher being a
baseball player Luke
ever since I started playing I mean I've
always when I didn't give it 100% and
never quitted anything mm-hmm and so you
know you were you were born with a right
arm but you lost it when you were 19
months old so basically you this is the
only life you've known is a one with a
left arm but not a right arm what made
you want to take up playing sports oh uh
my dad and granddad always played
baseball and then I've always watched it
and I've always just liked it and who's
she who's the guy that you you're a fan
of well I like bands we swap them okay
that's a good one
and who else uh Paulo fly work there's
another one okay so you're a fan of
which team I like the brave that's my
favorite okay
growing up in Tennessee you've been
watching the Braves and they're your
team how'd you get hooked up with the
Orioles Luke um well they contacted my
mom and asked if they could fly us up
there and uh the kokachin coach wanted
to do a bunch of drills with me and then
we flew up there and we did all kinds of
stuff and you play other sports other
than baseball no sir okay-y catching
well my granddad Colton I've seen my
cousins and all them play and then I'll
just I don't know it's like one of the
most active places and I was like yeah
okay Luke Terry corners old school
catcher who again who the video of him
catching caught so many people by
surprise and then of course so many
people wanting to reach out to Luke and
we were one of them here on the Rich
Eisen show do you do you hear from other
opponents who think that they could
steal on you because they only okay
so what do you think about that I don't
know when you say you don't know I mean
does that does it upset you is it does
it make you want to beat them throw them
out I mean what what what what do you
feel inside when you hear that sort of
stuff Luke yes kind of something I mean
yes trying to judge a book by its cover
but I mean really you don't know
how good the opponent is or anything
mm-hmm and then when it all comes down
to it what what do you think your best
your best move is Luke what do you think
your best move is to which base probably
second okay I mean how do you call signs
since that's obviously part of the sport
how does that go down although my glove
how does well I mean is it wrong for me
to ask you how you do it I mean I don't
want to give anything away it just
depends where I'll put it in this this
different time the pitchers will know
where it's at okay so that's how you
guys do that and you go through you go
through the whole drill before the game
well look and so I know cuz I called my
buddy Deion Sanders cuz he said you know
he tweeted out I don't know who this kid
is let's find out who he is I want to
give him equipment and all that I spoke
to him today he told me that you guys
connected last night right yes sir
what was that like they was nice so the
phone rings and you knew it was him or
what was that how'd that go oh my phone
bad at first and then I had to cut it
back down and I had a few missed calls
so I called him back
and then he was one of them okay who
else anybody else dropped some names
Luke come on this is it well she got
come on who else is called anybody else
that that's uh kind of famous that
reached out to you not really okay well
that's about to change so he wanted to
know basically last thing what your
sizes he said he didn't get that for me
so what is your size for your uniform
don't medium okay
adult medium for Luke Terry I'll pass
that along to I'll pass that along to
the D on Luke just want to just wanted
to reach out to you because obviously
you know it was moving to see and it's
great to see and I know it's something
that you just live with and and it's
nothing special to you but for a lot of
other people it's pretty damn inspiring
and certainly for somebody like myself
with the
I felt calm Bonnie saw she came Griffin
do what he did do did you see what she
came did at the combine yeah what do you
think of that there yeah I liked it yeah
bad Hey look you take care of yourself
all right and I look forward to eating I
look forward to seeing Gunn and more
people down now go back get back to
Spanish I don't want to discount is it a
grade down for you okay all right you
take care of Luke that's you guys Luke
Tara the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience